I was super interested in following the
g20 summit in Argentina over the last
few days in part because this is where I
was born my home city of Buenos Aires
Argentina but also because of the
interesting geopolitical dynamics that
have emerged recently and sort of seeing
how they would play out we saw this very
strange moment of Vladimir Putin and the
Saudi Crown Prince Mohammed bin Salman
high-fiving and hugging and just
genuinely thrilled to see each other of
course all in the context of the killing
of Jamal khashoggi in the context of
both Russia and Saudi Arabia apparently
having Donald Trump in their pocket that
was interesting to see I was interested
in seeing how the relationship would
reflect what is going on in terms of
tension between European countries and
of the United States of America also
Argentina involved in financial bailouts
with some of these countries I mean a
lot of interesting stuff going on but
near the top of the list
I was curious to see how would Donald
Trump behave given the insanity of the
last week given the Russia Trump Tower
leaks the Michael Cohen guilty pleas so
much imploding for Trump and Trump did
not disappoint or he did disappoint I
guess depending on your perspective in
an ideal world our president would be a
true ambassador for American values and
ideas around the world they would be
respected by other leaders and countries
we don't have that so the next ideal
situation would be well okay the
president would be someone who even if
not the best ambassador for us would at
least appear to be a professional when
they go to summits around the world
Trump can't do that either so if they're
not going to seem like a professional
ideally a president wouldn't throw a
tantrum and behave like a little kid on
the world stage and sadly that's exactly
what Donald Trump did when I was
watching the introductions and greetings
of each world leader with Argentinean
president Mauricio Macri I noticed that
something really strange happened and we
have video of it where Donald Trump had
a kind of strange exchange with the
president and then started walking away
the Argentinean president seemed kin
fused and some guy ran across the the
camera shot after Donald Trump wasn't
clear who it was and the argentinian
president seemed uncomfortable to say
the least turned around and i could only
imagine that this could only be more
interesting with the Curb Your
Enthusiasm thing song playing playing
over it I mean it was just a bizarre
bizarre exchange and it was initially
chalked up to a confusion about the
photo-op that was supposed to happen
next however it appears that this was
part of Trump behaving exactly like a
tantrum and kid the entire weekend
because he was recorded just off-camera
saying get me out of here to an aide as
the other leaders were gathering for a
picture here's the audio it's clear but
there is background noise so let's
listen to it together
yeah
Trump eventually reappeared and there
are a few angles here to consider so
first of all it's listen
Trump's panicking Trump's freaking out
about what's happening with Russia Saudi
Arabia
he's imploding and his presidency is
imploding in front of him and he just
has no attention span for the g20 and he
wanted to get the hell out of there
that would actually be reasonable I mean
I know when I have lots of things going
on it's tough to really focus on what
has to be done work chores whatever so
that's one possibility the other is that
Trump was upset because of how other
leaders were treating him I mean at this
point Trump is seen as a joke by leaders
around the world the Japanese prime
minister's wife previously pretended not
to understand English do not have to
track the talk to Trump France and the
UK and Germany increasingly don't even
invite Trump to anything related to
climate change and why would they what's
the point the guy thinks it's a hoax
concocted by China and if increasingly
Trump at these events is feeling left
out he's feeling like they don't care
about what he has to say given his
personality that would also
understandably make him furious and make
him want to leave and it is just one
embarrassment after the other all of the
horrible stereotypes about Americans
around the world that I tried to dispel
when I travel Donald Trump embodies down
to the finest detail I genuinely don't
know why the world even bothers with the
sky and the strongest counterpoint to
all of this that I read is this is
simply the scaling up of Trump's
cognitive decline that would actually be
the most inoffensive explanation because
hey it would just be a medical condition
and that would be far better than what
seemed to be serious personality flaws
that this guy has and a total inability
for self-reflection for introspection
that he has proven time again to be
completely incapable of doing on the
world stage am i misinterpreting what
happened in Argentina send me your
thoughts I'm on Twitter at D Pakman and
the show is on Twitter at David Pakman
show today's program is sponsored in
part by movement you've heard me talk
about them before movement watches were
founded on the belief that style
shouldn't break the bank the watches are
all
about looking good keeping it simple
they won't tell you how many steps
you've taken they won't allow you to
look at text messages on the phone they
tell time like timepieces should and my
experience with the watches have been
that people just love them everywhere I
go people I can tell they're not paying
attention to me they're distracted by
the watch and whatever I say hi I'm here
for my dental cleaning
could you please change the oil on my
car they say where'd you get that watch
that's what they're most interested in
and the watches start at just $95
meanwhile you go to traditional brands
and you're looking at four hundred five
hundred dollars even more for watches
that look this good
no wonder that movement has sold almost
two million watches in over a hundred
and sixty countries I have actually been
giving people gifts of movement watches
so far I've given three or four watches
out for the end of the year holiday
season if you need some help finding the
perfect gift this season you're not sure
where to start head over to movement
they did all the hard work they've
already curated their favorite styles
into gift boxes and packages and you can
get 15% off today with free shipping
free returns if you go to MVM t-dot-com
slash Pakman movement is launching new
styles on their site all the time check
out the latest at MVM t.com slash Pakman
one more time that's MVM t-dot-com /p a
que ma n join the movement